[MUSIC PLAYING]
(ON TV) A world of luxury
right at your fingertips.
Sheer opulence.
SHOP OWNER: You're
hardworking, reliable,
I want to promote you
to General Manager.
I'm afraid I cannot accept.
That was my dream
when I got here,
but my goals have
changed, I have changed.
I'm going to start
my own business.
A strip club for women.
Is this some kind of joke?
Not at all.
I mean, do you like
looking at naked dudes?
I have something to tell
you, Paul, women get horny.
Welcome to Chippendales.
I love this place.
You need me.
You need a choreographer,
and I do enjoy a challenge.
Cuffs and collars.
You are a genius.
This could be huge.
This could be global.
Russia, China,
the whole world.
Repeat after me, things
are going incredibly well.
Things are going
incredibly well.
And I'm not going to blow it.
Please welcome, Mr.
Chippendales himself,
Nick De Noia.
Chippendales is my
creation, I hired him.
NICK DE NOIA: You and me stick
together, or we go to war.
SOMEN BANERJEE:
Is that a threat?
It's a promise.
He's going to
walk all over you.
SOMEN BANERJEE: Every cent I
have I've put into this club.
I need this.
I don't mind that
you do shady things.
PROTESTERS: Shame on you!
I will not allow
you to do them badly.
Oh yeah, blood will spill.
We have to call the cops.
No, we do
not call the cops!
[SCREAMS]
FBI AGENT: (ON PHONE) Mr.
Banerjee, this is the FBI.
I'm the boss!
You're a murderer!
I have everything
and I regret nothing.
I'm going to burn his
place to the ground.
You a bad man, Mr. Banerjee.
You ain't seen nothing yet.
[MUSIC PLAYING] Oh, she
said, anyway you want it,
that's the way you need it.
Anyway you want.